I've had to make statements like this
too many times communities like this
have had to endure tragedies like this
too many times we don't have all the
facts but we do know that once again
innocent people were killed in part
because someone who wanted inflict harm
had no trouble getting their hands on a
gun now is the time for mourning and for
healing but let's be clear at some point
we as a country will have to reckon with
the fact that this type of mass violence
does not happen in other advanced
countries as a country we have been
through this too many times whether it's
an elementary school in Newton or a
shopping mall in Oregon or a temple in
Wisconsin or a movie theater in Aurora
or a street corner in Chicago these
neighborhoods are our neighborhoods
we're going to have to take meaningful
action to prevent more tragedies like
this from happening I will do everything
in my power as president to advance
these efforts look this is a state that
has suffered the tragedy of two of the
worst mass shootings in our history the
day Newtown happened was the toughest
day of my presidency if there's just one
thing we can do to keep one father from
having to bury his child isn't that
worth fighting for they blocked
common-sense gun reforms even while
these families looked on from the Senate
gallery we are confronting yet another
mass shooting we've got to get back up
and go back at it because as long as
there are those who fight to make it as
easy as possible for dangerous people to
get their hands on gun then we've got to
work as hard as possible for the sake of
our children we've gotta be ones who are
willing to do more work to make it
harder